das hier ist ein extra long Big Mac und
das ist alles was wir brauchen einmal
Rindfleisch für Smash Patties dann
Cheddar Käse Gewürzgurken ganz wichtig
Big Mac Soße Salat und unser Sandwich
unser Brot ist jetzt halbiert und ich
röste es in Butter auf der planscher an
wenn unser Sandwich so aussieht können
wir es von Grillen Ober und Unterseite
mit Big Mac Soße bestreichen das Rezept
dazu gibt es in meinem Youtube Video
nehmen wir Eisbergsalat dann können wir
auch schon anfangen unsere Patties zu
Smash hat ein klassischer Big Mac nicht
aber das ist ja auch alles andere als
klassisch hier goldbraun anbraten und
jedes Fetti kriegt eine Scheibe Käse zum
brutal
guckt euch das einfach mal an diese
Kruste crazy Mama mir also das ist
wirklich brutal Deckel drauf